are you a Christian no you're not do you
believe in God I don't so are you an
atheist
I I have an absence of belief in God if
you want to call that atheism
it could be agnosticism I'm not really
sure but I have an absence of belief in
God but it's not like I'm not going
around telling people God doesn't exist
it's sort of like if we heard a noise in
the back right now I wouldn't say to you
that was probably an invisible purple
hippopotamus
I have no evidence that that's what it
is I would say it's probably a noise
caused by something we've seen something
we can prove something there's evidence
for I wouldn't tell you invisible
purpose purple hippopotamuses don't
exist or could never exist right I just
have no reason to think that that's what
caused the noise